[Music]
well when I was thinking about this
discussion I read Lawrence Krauss whose
book something from nothing because
that's the most popular visual version
of this debate from the cosmological
point of view at the moment and what
struck me about it and what struck me
about most arguments is how conservative
they are if you look at traditional
discussions of why there's something
rather than nothing the traditional ones
are theological discussions they start
from the assumption that there's a
source of all things which is threefold
in kashmir shaivism
it's called para shiva the unified
source of all things with Shiva which
represents the principle of form or
order and Shakti which represents the
principle of energy or power in the
Christian version of the Holy Trinity
you have God the ground of all being you
have the Lagos which is the mind of God
the form the source of all forms and you
have the spirit which is the source of
energy movement in power but at Lawrence
Krauss you have a source which he
doesn't discuss but it has two
manifestations one the laws of nature
which may be the field of all possible
laws of nature that may apply to all
universes but that's taken for granted
as pre-existing and then you have the
quantum vacuum which is the source of
all potential energy and power for this
and all other universes in other words
it's exactly like Shakti and his role of
the laws of nature is exactly like Shiva
or all the log asks on the spirit so the
the this seemingly radical atheistic
view is extraordinarily conservative in
philosophical and theological terms it
just rephrases them and with a few kind
of polemical jabs against sort of
old-fashioned theologians he's basically
restated the ancient case for the
existence of God
he goes even further he says in that the
it's the nature of the quantum vacuum is
so unstable that it almost inevitably
would give rise to a universe through a
kind of fluctuation say okay let's look
at Genesis chapter one verse one the
earth was without form at the world
without form and void and the Spirit of
God moved on the face of the deep or the
face of the waters
well the quantum vacuums pretty well a
modern version of the face of the deep
and if the Spirit of God the wind moves
on the face of the deep it creates waves
and the waves presumably follow a law
like structure so what struck me about
all this was that the debate is
essentially a theological debate that's
been reframed in these modern physical
terms and the really interesting
question for me about it is that in the
theological debate the ground of all
this is conscious where as for Lawrence
Krauss and materialists an atheist the
ground of all this is unconscious no
it's a matter of faith either way I
suppose but as far as I can see the
advantage of the ultimate ground of
being being conscious has first of all
you don't you're dead there's a basis
for these rational laws instead of the
laws of nature being free-floating
mathematical abstractions that are
outside space and time that apply to all
possible universes that are ultimately
metaphysical in the ultimate sense of
metaphysics as being beyond physics that
there you got free-floating laws which
have no ontological basis whatever and
then you have human minds that appear
mysteriously in an unconscious universe
and can actually understand these laws
are though we've evolved by evolutionary
psychology of sort of using stone tools
and primitive campfire type techniques
our minds are somehow able to comprehend
the entire universe so that there can be
someone like Krauss putting forward
theories about the ultimate nature of
reality well if there's a conscious
basis for both reality
and for human minds the traditional view
this makes a lot more sense take that
away and we're left with a kind of
unconscious version of traditional
theology and a lack of explanation for
the existence of minds of any kind
including those of physicists which in
philosophy of mind is called the hard
problem for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you